a ourself a speaker for this
presentation is you Val field moves from
the University of Toronto give it was
about three foot kalaya whole for
boolean functions of it right this is
the same record I was a traditional so
yeah so i will talk about extensions of
the finger clean out the tuna seven and
this is all joint work with david ellis
if you've just seen and effort fringes
okay so a starting point would be to
explain what is the classical critically
our theorem now this is one of these
basic theorem which are considered by
some to be very basic and important
although we hard for us to present
actual applications beyond the original
ones so we're just take it for granted
and then we'll take it for granted that
it's nice to generalize things and then
you'd be happy and motivated so yeah
let's start with the classical serum and
we'll start with the the FK m TM v 0 so
suppose should not get the free plane or
theorem suppose F is a boolean function
so this time boolean is going to be plus
minus 1 other points will be 0 1 they
please suppose if it's of the form f of
x1 to xn is equal to a0 plus South AI x
I ok so it's an effing function and also
happens to be boolean so how can this
happen like what with what devious ways
can you make it happen so there no
devious ways are so there are two
possibilities either F is constant or
its X I or minus X I
okay so this is our starting point so
this theme is rather easy to prove that
you just square f it equals 1 you do the
math and you get the result okay now
suppose suppose F is still a boolean
function and now instead of it being
equal exactly to this a 0 plus some of
AIX I then it's approximately equal to
this FN function so what can you say now
can you now do something interesting is
there now a different way to be almost
bullion without being essentially
constant or dictatorship so that's where
the friedrich early in our theme kicks
in and it says no actually the only way
to beat even closely satisfy this
condition is by being basically one of
these functions so this will be the
edward cullen over here so again f is
this buoyant function
and suppose that it satisfies so it's
close to this a fine combination in what
sense in our two cents
so in that case for some function G
inside in this collection
f is close to G how close order epsilon
close to to this very simple function so
it's a stability version of this very
easy theorem the physical in our theorem
itself is more interesting to prove
there are many different proofs and you
actually have to do something
unfortunately I don't have time to
explain exactly what ok so I started
down this talk by saying that the field
line or theam isn't actually as useful
as you might think but it does have some
applications in elvish collado theory so
if you wanted to prove the stability
version of the Elder Scroll this year so
now you have this your intersecting
family of sense so for some settings of
the parameter then the maximum family is
at most a dictatorship so now we know
that if you are if you have contained so
many sets and you must be a max one of
these is a very simple families a
dictatorship so now suppose that your
you contain almost as many sets can you
not be something very different so
essentially the free food coloring or
theorem says that even if you're just
almost maximal then you're essentially
close to one of these very simple
families so this is one way to interpret
the fkn theam and this also leads us to
consider this theorem in sm for the very
application that david was explaining in
the last talked so in their paper at
least with guten pupil they deduce is
stability version of of this a discarded
theorem for SN and they need to to when
they do the stability analysis they need
to use the fact that the family is
intersecting but if you want to do it in
a more general way want to be able to
deduce the same thing just from the fact
that F has a very simple form and what
is this simple form
so here's what we get from their nalgas
so let's call this f KN 0 so this is a
version of f KN 0 for SN and this is the
theorem that was might have been first
proved by the Sega Valley or maybe
someone else Gao who knows so suppose
that F is a function from SN and this
time is going to be 2 0 1 and f is of
the following form so f is a linear
combination of these one concepts so
here these CI J's are the indicators for
the event that the fermentation maps I
to J
then that case f is a dictatorship okay
so what do I mean by a dictatorship so
there are two ways to look at it so
either the function f depends only on
the image of some point so it depends on
Y on some pie or it depends on you on
the inverse image of some point x minus
1 05 so
so this is one way of defining a
dictatorship the other way of defining
it achieve is as the disjoint union of
one cassettes is the same thing yeah so
what this theorem states is that if F is
this a finer linear function a
combination of this one costs it then
it's essentially a nice combination of
these one causes again as they would
mention this theorem is somewhat more
challenging to prove okay so now what
would be the fkn version of this year so
this is the version of fkn for sm and
i'm writing this in red because what I'm
going to write is going to be wrong and
after we corrected this in red because
it's only conjectured so suppose F from
SN 201 close to this linear combination
so gain the same thing
then for some leadership G
f is close to G
okay so this is a false conjecture okay
so why is this conjecture false so
here's a counter example
you need time to think if the current
example on your own then you take the
function f which is the union of
cassettes t1 1 and T 2 2 so this is the
function which is very close to the
function of this form say t1 1 plus T 2
2 but it's not close to any dictatorship
okay so so this theorem is a bit too
optimistic so instead we have to fix it
this is because epsilon and should not
depend on n is it no so the thing is
that when your allow error then you can
actually be close to to being a linear
combination of closets without being
close to an actual disjoint some of
closets yeah if there's no air than this
can't happen because when your closets
are not disjoint in there is some error
but the point is that the intersection
of two closets is very small yeah so yes
everything is relative yeah it's like
the epsilon here is going on 1 over N
squared and and here if you actually
want to dictatorship you get 1 over n
which is a huge difference okay so this
is if you replace it with oh yeah it
could could be the case we don't know we
do have results that have scored epsilon
in the statement but they don't answer
your question
yeah but richer ice and it's actually a
very natural solution to this to this
problem I guess in a sense this result
is yeah ok so this conductor might also
be false it's just conjecture do you
believe in Demon's wish treasure let's
connect here I definitely be releasing
Josh okay so we might have different
opinions but this conjecture might be
true instead I'll instead of proving the
conjecture which we don't know how to do
I'll give you two examples of things we
do know how to do so we have one result
which makes sense for balance functions
and the other one which makes sense for
sparse functions okay so this is a
trilogy of papers about only mention the
first two of them by these group of
three authors so our result for spice
functions
so suppose asses from SN 2 0 1 and F is
close to their combination
then for some
p which is
the union of not necessarily disjoint
giving of m of c 1 concepts where c is
the number of questions that you expect
this family to have so if the
expectation divided by 1 over n which is
the expectation of the one constant so
for some g which is going of this many
concepts then the difference the error
this is from F to G so here is my
promise squirt epsilon
yeah negative right yeah yeah so so you
have your function which is close to
being a linear combination of op 1
concepts and we're going to come up with
some other function G which is the union
of what not necessarily disjoint one
closets and is close to your function
but there's some problems with this
close here so instead of epsilon gets
squirt epsilon which might might mix it
might even make sense but not not with
these factors we don't really want this
factor this factor means the rest
epsilon tends to 0 then there's don't
actually improve and we don't want this
factor C so but as long as is your fun
as long as you're this function f is
sparse then it's fine so if F consists
just off a few concepts then the sea is
constant and this result is meaningful
so this is one result the others all ya
see is a number of cross section and
this notation it means round floor
ceiling w-2 so now a result for balance
functions
Oh
so again we have the function f dang
close to something then for some
dictatorship G
I'm sorry to keep you so suspenseful and
suspense so yeah so the distance from F
to G squared we would like it to be
order epsilon but instead what we get is
instead of epsilon we get f 10 to the 17
and again we get this fudge factor which
means that when anthem is really small
we don't get anything better and there's
also a factor that depends on how
balance the function is so if F is bad
so it's half 0 half one or maybe
one-third two-thirds then this factor is
a constant but if it's really unbalanced
like in this case then this doesn't give
you a lot okay so these are the two
results that we get so before I turn
into the proofs then think about it for
a few seconds and if you have any
questions I will take them
there may be just a quick coin and we we
basically conjecture and this and the
first statement is tree and that just
with bigger of epsilon times either bit
bigger that's on time Jax rotation about
now that should be true always but we
get the same as this condition so this
is conjecture after it was collected is
stronger than both of them yeah yeah so
again here you have this extra attacker
see you have this factor 1 over N and in
phila pepsin we get square root epsilon
if instead of this year the epsilon you
didn't have this and didn't have to see
them this is just a conjecture and here
if you didn't have the etta if you
didn't have this and if you didn't help
this then you got the conjecture now
it's probably possible to remove these
factors and to replace the seven with
something smaller but I don't think our
methods can be optimized to give this
conductor was the worst dependence on a
chilly yes it's possible also I didn't
mention that there are other
generalizations of fkn to other public
spaces summer when the space is not the
product space then you need to be to
work a little harder okay good so in the
rest of the time I will prove to you one
of these results so which one do you
prefer yeah that's also what I prefer so
lucky for you so here's what we will
actually prove so to make life easier we
will assume that the function is exactly
balanced
so slightly change the prioritization so
suppose F is a function from sm 2 plus
minus 1 and f expectation 0 so it's
fifty percent 30 50 fish and false and
also so here we took any linear
combinations but I think you can just
take the projection this is going to
give you the smallest error so suppose
that the distance from f2f1 squared is
epsilon where f 1 is the projection f to
the span of these 1 closets
then f is close to a dictatorship G now
since we're not going to see any epsilon
is in the actual schedule them it
doesn't really matter what i mean by
close here
so the proof is composed of two parts
but before that no no so it's not true
for four dictatorships like the example
T 1 192 two shows yeah so no one yeah
yeah so known as why there is a
difference so the difference is if you
have a ton of cassettes and they're not
disjoint then the intersections actually
accumulate and they amount to something
so in the dense case you can actually
guarantee that they are destroyed so
even this general conjectures I'm
erasing right now when the function is
once you can strengthen it and say that
you're close to a dictatorship okay so
one thing that is annoying but working
with these double closets which is one
closet is that they're not linearly
independent so there are actually many
ways of representing f1 as a linear
combination of t IJ and what I'm going
to do is we're going to choose a
particular asymmetric way oh yeah easy
claim so f1 is equal to the sum of a IJ
IJ where
hey I'm Jay is n minus 1 times the
correlation between f and g IJ ok so f1
is this production of death to the son
of the tij so we know it has to be this
one and you do some calculation and
that's what you get I can say that the
view perhaps would expect the factor and
here but because the costs are not
disturbed you only get n minus 1 and
more generally if the function wasn't
balanced that you would need to add some
factor here but in the balance case it's
very nice so let's look at an example
so let's look at the function f which is
G 11 in the Union t1 and over 2 so this
is just a function of the form of we're
after so how does this matrix so I think
of this a IJ is a matrix how does this
matrix look so the matrix a IJ has a
following form
so on the first row which corresponds to
the interesting role you have entries
which are after you won or minus one so
it's one if you contain the coaster and
minus 12 don't contain it and there's of
the entries are small so now there are
two striking things about this matrix
one of them is that all the rows and the
columns sum to zero which is always very
nice the other thing is from this matrix
how do I determine the value of f1 on
any particular permutation so we just
substitute the formula
so every permutation pie corresponds to
some what we call it generalizes
diagonal or some matching between the
rows and columns and you just sounded
values in this generalized diagonal and
that gives you the value of the f1 so
for example if you some if you live by
is the identity permutation then you
have to solve the main diagonal and if
you do it then you will get one in this
case ok so and now that we have the
background down I can explain how the
proof is going to go so they're going to
be two parts so plans of proof so steps
one and two we're going to show that
almost all generals diagonals have
exactly one like element whereby like I
mean something that is close to plus
minus one so we show that almost
all generalized diagonals and exactly
one large element suppose to plus minus
one yeah exactly so this is the elephant
a part of the proof so suppose that this
were true for all the divisional eyes
diagonals then what I we said is exactly
true so the nemetrix must look like this
basically there must be either row or a
column which can contain consists only
of large elements so in step 3 we prove
a stability version of a visa lemma so
we deduce that the matrix NJ
as what we call a strong line so a line
is either a row or a column where most
of the entries are large
yeah and for this particular step step
three nothing know anything about it
doesn't it's it's an abstract statement
it doesn't apply only to this problem
it's more general so you have this
matrix and you have some definition of
large element it doesn't matter what so
you have a size 0 1 matrix and for
almost all generalized eigen halls there
is exactly one stronger one large
gentleman so it has to be this strong
line okay and this stuff is also nice
because if you start with the fraction
of 1 minus epsilon then you end up with
a line with y minus order epsilon large
island so you don't lose anything you
lose everything in the first steps
and once we have this online then we're
basically done so because each line sums
to zero so approximately half the
entries are close to one and half a
close to minus one so you take the one
closet that correspond to the ones and
now what's the meaning of this a IJ it's
how much of this costed your family
contains so you're actually your family
contains most of these long closets so
here we have two families your original
family and this union of one closets and
they are both of roughly the same size
and one of them contains most of the
other so they must be really close so
picture looks like this so we have two
circles of the same side and they have
really light intersection so this fact
must be small yes on iOS 92 steps three
and four I didn't explain how I proved
this stability version of Abby's lemma
that it's doable so now just remains to
show how we how we do the first part of
the proof and so any questions regarding
this plan of the proof
okay so we start with the first step
it's always a good idea so the idea is
to look at the restrictions of ff12 all
permutations sending some set I to some
set j or yes so at MVB subsets and at
the same size so we define tab2 be the
set of permutations let's n HB set and
let G be the restriction of f12 ta be ok
now what do we know about this function
G so we can decompose it as two
functions so the first function only
depends on the value of the input on the
set a and the other one only depends on
the values of the input on the
complement of a so we can write e equals
G 1 plus G to wear whether g of 5
because g 1 of 5 6 into a plus G 25
restricted to the complement of a where
G 1 of 5 52 a it's just a son
this orangey to something similar yeah
so did I call in the eyes okay now
here's a picture so suppose this is your
set a so this is your set a and this is
your set B so the function G 1 Satan's
here OMG one only depends on the stuff
here and the function G to only depends
on the stuff here you can imagine that
both of them actually squares yeah and
the key idea here is that g1 and g2 are
sort of two independent functions that
sum to a function which is almost
boolean so we can say something about
them so for most searches of a and B
what happens
so one is that G is close to plus minus
one in various senses for example point
wise it's close to plus minus ones most
of the time and the second thing which
might not be as obvious is that the
expectations of g1 and g2 are roughly
zero and the reason this is the case is
because the lines of the rows and
columns some 20 okay so now what do we
have we have our function G which is the
sum of g1 and g2 which are sort of
independent and g is almost bullion so
how can that be the one of the functions
must be constant and the other one must
be not attain two values now until the
expectation is roughly zero then this
concept must be 0 so the only way in
which this can happen is that one of
these functions is roughly zero and the
other one is roughly bullying so since t
is so this can only happen
if g one is roughly zero and g2 is
roughly platforms one or vice versa okay
so this is a step one
now here when I when I say almost zero
almost 5-1 I mean that it's true
pointwise so for most permutations in
this ta be in the domain of G it's
actually the case that if you calculate
g1 on the corresponding part of the
permutation and the result will be close
to zero flows to plus minus 1 so now to
get this conclusion we sort of switch
the expectations and instead of first
using a and B and then choosing the
permutation inside we do it the other
way around so step 2 so for most
permutations 5 through that for most and
be compatible with five
now wats and be compatible define it
means that V is part of a so for most a
and B is through that g one of pi is
close to zero and g25 is close to either
plus or minus one or vice versa ok now
what is G one-five so g15 so some a i
feii and g25 some of i evolved a i feii
so I'm worried what happens here so you
look at this journalize diagonal that
corresponds to pi and you break it
translate into two parts and you
recklessly most of the time one of them
sounds 20 and the other one comes to
plus minus one and roughly so there are
two ways in which this can happen so
there must be some element which decides
the outcome and this I'm excited is a
very close to one or very close to minus
one so if it's very close to one then
whichever have it falls this is a half
against 271 and if it's minus one then
it's whatever half a dozen folder is
going to sum to one or the other
possible you okay so this can only
happen
if the stellas back home
sometimes
exactly one element goes to plus or
minus one which is just like we wanted
to show okay so we got that almost all
during life diagonals have exactly one
element which is light goes to plus
minus one and that implies that there is
this strong line either row or column in
which most of the answers from and then
by taking all the elements of course
that are close to one in this line then
we get the dictatorship which is a good
approximation to our function ok so I
think my time is over almost we don't
have to use all your time yeah okay so i
think i'll let you spend a few more
minutes are contemplating what you've
just heard and if you have any question
as well please ask yeah
excellent question yes yeah so obvious
for a version of the okay so I'm
slightly lying so there's a variant yeah
so now you're considering a function on
the bullion slice okay so this is the
sense in which I understand the question
so we have a function on the bullion
slice and due to the slice which is not
like completely ridiculous and your
function is close to being a fine and
it's also boolean so this function must
be close to educate artists like I mean
it says more but don't you use this kind
of so yeah that's an interesting
question so this this result is new and
the way it works is by reduction to the
original Afghan theorem so it could be
that you could apply the same technique
to work in sm y a few people in the
simon thing to do I can I can list the
nose so I just don't want to list too
many or too too few people people get
can get you know hurt
extending our functions to hire the
different numbers another excellent
question so this is what happens in the
paper eff three so there what you have
so festively in the boolean case then
this is known as the kindle app for
theorem which is as an interesting
publication history so the only known
publish roof appears in guy candles
teases the only quotable sizable one so
yeah in the classical setting
so if F times flies
the calf is concentrating on the first K
levels then for some be depending on Oh
tilde X on at all in k coordinates
this is between F&G squared is honor
epsilon so so we're trying to generalize
this so to complete your competitive
square and the analog here in this case
one possible analog yeah so this is a
kindle sample get a free so now we have
a function f from sm 2 0 1 and f is
epsilon close to some see a V T V where
is it mostly so now instead of being
close to some of one concepts it's close
to some of key concepts then there
exists this
so I guess I want it to be epsilon
expected value of F flow let's see if I
can abstract and exists a function G
which is the union
of C key concepts
where c is roughly prediction with death
over 1 over N to the T and
this order of squirt epsilon plus C over
square root n times this mutation of
that or something like that yep yeah so
this is food in a way which is similar
to eff one you haven't explained but
much more complicated and interesting
and involves an interesting
generalization of the cauchy-schwarz
there so if you like inequalities then
there's something there for you we
haven't tried to generalize eff to four
key concepts so here it's actually false
so you might think that if you start
with the function which is close to the
first grade levels and it has to be
close to a que canta what it's false you
actually have to get to exponentially
larger set and here's not the case but
maybe if you're a balanced one can
anticipate or maybe it's not the case
because in SN each concept is only one
of our analysts here it was it is like
one half we're not really yeah
you have all functions work
hello sighs I'm with
so now this is a distribution that is
only
everything is already known but you seem
like an example of tea 11 or equal to
it's still there except for something
that is one words but 1 over X that
that's true so let's say I what's going
yeah so we were doesn't lose epsilon
mrs. food at see them so so shocked is
not here so the answer exists and it's
in this paper generalizing fkn to
product spaces but I have never read it
thoroughly enough and it does anyone do
they all know the answer which producer
so internalization of fkn to general
product spaces usually sushant such data
and dilution is not been found three
okay yeah yeah so actually yes so this
old paper covers your case but I don't
remember the answer so it might be that
you get some constant there that is
going to depend on n say so you are
going to get like n times so if you're
going to so that one's going to graduate
yeah that that's my guess that's my
guess you can may I you can generate
those of two intersecting computations
in various ways not reserving this way
look at the set of a transposition of
the connotation and after the every to
rotation will have some common sign over
you can talk about the decent set of the
many statistics for conversation and
many sets so they'd like to mention that
you actually has a result in this in
this direction so it turns out that from
the point of view of representation
theory there is a very economical way of
defining these intersections so for any
partition land of em you can say so
number one on the K partition and say
that Sigma and tau are lambda
intersecting
if Sigma and tau agree on some partition
of the space for some tradition
thanks where your status of sighs
exactly down down so for example if your
partition is n minus t 1 11111 three
times then you get exactly two
intersecting permutations if your lambda
is n minus TT then you get tea set
intersecting permutations so you're to
permutations agree on some set of size t
and for this particular case they will
prove the equivalent of the elder
scrolls theorem and uniqueness stability
and everything for general lambda I even
asked about some differences there are
different things on the transportation
say yeah here is an idea and it is if
you say any cheap imitations have to
actively on robots based on something on
the syringe a source of Sigma vehicles
and five giant sigma j equals prioritize
some child
missions with false